الحرب مشاهدينا في اوكرانيا تتواصل ويزداد
الدعم لها وهو يعني بشكل مباشر امتلاء
جيوب مصنعي الاسلحه وخزائن الدول نقص
الانتاج الذي يواجه الموردين التقليديين
كالولايات المتحده مثلا ادخل دولا اخرى
على الخط وناخذ مثلا كوريا الجنوبيه
تدخلت لسد الفجوه بينما تحاول عدم استفزاز
موسكو تحركت كوريا الجنوبيه بوتيره سريعه
لانتاج المزيد من الصواريخ والدبابات
وقذائف المدفعيه والذخائر في العام الماضي
ارتفعت صادرات كوريا الجنوبيه من الاسلحه
بنسبه 140 في المئه الى مستوى قياسي بلغ
17 مليار و300 مليون دولار الصعود في خط
الانتاج هو عائد لتلبيه الطلب من قواتها
المسلحه وللحمايه طبعا من كوريا الشماليه
في منطقه اخرى كشفت الصناعات الحربيه
التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه ان
العام الجاري سيشهد قفزه في حجم مبيعات
الاسلحه واوضح التقارير الاسرائيليه ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا قلبت المعادلات في
العالم لتصبح الدول الاوروبيه اكثر
استعدادا لشراء الاسلحه والعتاد والذخيره
الاسرائيليه الصنع
ايضا رحب الامين العام لحلف الناتو يانس
بخطوات المجره نحو الموافقه على انضمام
السويد الى الحلف
حتى الان صدق ثمانيه وعشرون من الحلفاء
الثلاثين وبعد ذلك بالطبع امل واحث
الحليفين المتبقيين المجر وتركيا على
القيام بذلك في اقرب وقت ممكن اعلن
البرلمان المجري عن خطه للقيام بذلك قرب
نهايه الشهر ثم مع زياره الوفد للسويد
لارسال رساله ايجابيه اعتقد اننا نحرز
تقدما ونقترب من التصديق ايضا في المجر